[Music]
it has been 121 days since the aliens
invaded our world
we have suffered
[Music]
we have sacrificed
lives
loved ones
connection it's the only chance we'll
have to learn what they want
and how to stop them
[Music]
enemy together we will win this war
somehow connected us
this is our last chance for survival
I know it sounds mental it does sound
mental The Whole World's mental right
the world out there is falling apart
to hold this family together
they adapted wheeler death
what if you could save everybody
[Music]
if you want to win the war
fight back
[Music]
yeah
all right here
are you sure you want to do this
[Music]
foreign